At the very young age
of less than one year old,
a violent civil war broke out
in my home country
of the Democratic Republic of Congo.
As a result, my family was forced to flee.
And as luck would have it,
we found safety in Kyangwali refugee camp,
located in western Uganda,
where I grew up from
and have learned to call home
for the past 24 years.
Every morning, my two parents
would wake up at 5am
and leave for the fields where they went
to cultivate our small garden,
to plant maize and beans
to feed the family.
And every evening
when they came back home,
they would end the night in the same way.
Usually, they would gather me
and my siblings
and would give us a pep talk
on how much they desired for us
to go to school and be educated.
Surprisingly, none of my parents
actually had gone to school.
But to them, education
meant securing a well-paying job
at some point in the future.
And with this, we [could] afford
the three meals a day.
We perhaps could build
a nice-looking house for our family
or even decide to take our family
from the refugee camp to the city.
And so when I started going to school,
I took this [to] heart
and I took school seriously.
Even though I was just a little kid,
I managed to wake myself out of bed,
take all three goats to graze
and be back on time
to dress up and go to school.
Classes in the refugee camp
can be overcrowded.
I was one of the nearly 200 students
who sat in a single classroom
as I tried to focus and learn.
But besides the problem
of overcrowded classrooms,
we also had an issue
whereby most of our learning
was characterized by rote memorization.
On a typical day,
we showed up in a classroom,
copied down notes that teachers gave us
and were expected to go back home
[and] cram these in preparation for exams.
And if I can be honest with you,
I did not enjoy this.
We barely interacted with our teachers
and even amongst ourselves.
And even though as serious students,
most of the time,
school seemed to be very boring.
However, as I was growing up
and as I took on the routine
of going to school in the morning
and then coming back
to my family in the evening,
there seemed to be one thing
and one thing only,
that truly held my attention,
and that was the idea of playing games.
And I most loved playing
the game of football.
Now I will start off by addressing
the biggest elephant in the room.
I know most of you love American football,
but actually that's not the game
I'm talking about.
I’m five foot three, and given my size,
I truly can't play American football.
So I’m actually talking about football,
where we use our feet, and that’s soccer.
I also loved playing the cards of spades.
And most of the time after school
I would come to my house,
and I would be holding a deck of cards.
And every time my parents saw me
shuffling these cards,
they would be paranoid,
thinking I'd started gambling.
But I wasn't.
And perhaps because I then
didn't have money to do so.
No wonder,
while in high school in 2016,
the idea of gamification
became the best solution
I thought about I could use
to be able to address the problem
in the refugee camp.
And since then,
I've been on a quest
to make education more accessible
and more fun and engaging for children
within Kyangwali refugee camp
through the use of board games.
And if you don't mind,
I'm going to share
with you how it all happened.
One year before, in 2015,
I was lucky and got an opportunity to go
and study at African Leadership Academy,
located in Johannesburg, South Africa.
And here I was introduced to the idea
of entrepreneurship for the first time.
And my amazing teachers taught me
that entrepreneurs
were simply problem solvers.
And I immediately knew that I wanted
to work on an education problem.
The first idea I thought:
I could build a primary school.
More children would
access learning spaces,
teachers would not have the problem
of overcrowded classrooms.
But the problem was I was 19 years old,
didn’t have the money,
didn't have the skills of what it took
to build a primary school.
The second idea I thought:
I could advocate
for a well-equipped library.
With this, we would have enough
textbooks in the library,
and children would have enough
reading materials.
They would do it at school
in performing in the national exams.
However, I had one issue with the library.
You see, food can be scarce
in the refugee camp,
and several times
when I showed up at school,
I personally remembered every time
I entered in the library,
all I could think about was food.
More than anything, I needed
a solution that was cheap,
a solution that was credible,
and something that would be
very exciting to the children.
Something that somehow
would help these children
forget about their hunger
and then engage with running.
But also something that would help
teachers have control
on overcrowded classrooms.
But most importantly,
help children engage with algebra,
with the science they were learning,
and have fun every single day
they came to school.
And so even though I had never
taken drawing classes,
I picked up a pencil and got some courage
to start making sketches
of what would be my first board game.
I also generated
a number of trivia questions
and then called up my former primary
school teacher in Kyangwali refugee camp.
And I asked if I could visit
my primary school once again.
He was generous, and he said yes.
When I showed up at my former
primary school,
the kids were excited,
and most of them
jumped out of their seats
when I told them what I held
in my hands was a board game.
Surprisingly, none of them actually
knew even how the game was played.
But heading towards the board game,
they were thrilled.
Working with the teachers
and the school administration,
they give me about one hour to test out
the game for the next couple weeks.
And the game was a huge success.
So much so, that the next morning
my mom woke me out of bed
telling me that there was
a group of children
wearing my school uniform, looking for me.
I was still confused because it was
about 6am in the morning.
But I woke up out of my bed,
still in my night dress actually,
and then opened the door.
There was about six children,
and when I looked at them,
there were about two faces
that I could recognize.
There was James and Patrick,
two of the children
I had worked with the previous day.
And with the most innocent faces
that I have ever seen,
they were like, “Could you come
and join us at school,
and then we play the game
before school starts?”
And looking at their faces,
there was no way I was going to say no.
I said, "I'll dress up
and meet you over by school."
And this group of amazing children
became my early testers.
We would play the game in the morning,
and then in the afternoon, as they waited
for their afternoon shift.
And today,
the game has evolved into what
my team and I at My Home Stars,
a nonprofit we are running in Uganda,
have called the 5 STA-Z
educational board game.
And here is how the 5 STA-Z
education board works.
At the beginning,
a classroom divides itself
into groups of five children.
And these children
begin interacting with one another
on questions and content we've developed
in partnership
with a group of 16 teachers.
All this content is a reflection
of the actual content
covered in the Ugandan educational
curriculum of mathematics,
English, science and social studies.
And as they interact,
they get to earn points
for every trivia question they get right.
And they use these points to advance
around the star-shaped board
with a goal of being the first one
to enter the middle
and take on the big yellow star,
which usually gets children very excited.
My team and I also have worked together
to incorporate game mechanics
such as chance and jeopardy,
where children actually
can earn extra points
when they collaborate and help each other
with difficult trivia questions.
This has been intended to make sure
that children actually are learning
the components of communication
and working together in teams.
But also it makes learning
become more child-centered.
And actually, teachers can focus
on groups of children
that are struggling most,
a model that we are finding
to be very helpful
in communities such as refugee camps,
where most of the time
we don't have enough teachers.
And there's one particular reason
as to why my team and I decided
to call the game the 5 STA-Z.
And it's simply the conviction
that no matter where you're from
and the current existing circumstances,
we can all reach for the stars.
And like Neil deGrasse Tyson would put it,
not only do we live among the stars,
the stars themselves live within us.
And that includes children
from refugee camps.
And as children also start
playing the game,
we encourage them
not to use their actual names,
but actually to take on the characters
of the five brightest stars in the galaxy.
And that’s Canopus, Rigel,
Arcturus, Vega and Sirius.
And also, when we hand them
the board game,
we remind them that they are already stars
who are interacting with one another
to help each other
just shine a little bit brighter.
And perhaps our biggest impact
was realized in 2020 and 2021.
Like most of you remember,
these are the two years when COVID-19
pandemic decided to visit us.
And during this time,
classes in the refugee camp closed,
and children were sent home with no way
of accessing learning resources.
My team and I took on the challenge
to make learning happen within homes,
and we produced about 1,000 game packages
that we gave to teachers
and community leaders.
And with this, we’re able to help
about 5,000 children
to access home learning
in the most fun and engaging way
through the use of board games.
Today, we are working with five schools
in Kyangwali refugee camp
where we’ve actually been able to work
with school administration
to make the 5 STA-Z part
of the learning schedules.
In the morning,
children spend the morning time
learning the normal classes
they're supposed to take in the curriculum
and then spend about one hour
in the afternoon
to put what they've learned
in the morning into practice.
Beyond being a game that is helping
children master the curriculum content
and do well in the national exam,
my team and I are committed
to continue building the 5 STA-Z
into a learning resource
that will continue to put a smile
on these children's faces,
every single day they come to class
and a game that can continue
to inspire them
into what is possible
for them in the future.
And also, we are committed
to continue building this game
into a game that we shall be able to make
available to other children
in other refugee camps across Uganda
and other countries
across the African continent.
In the past one year,
about 100 million people across
the world have been displaced,
and many of these
are the result of a civil war.
From Kyangwali refugee camp
in western Uganda
to New York City
and standing in front of you today
and engaging with you
is a big, big, big privilege.
And the only reason I'm able to do so
and stand in front of you,
is because I've been given
an opportunity to go to school.
And while board games such as the 5 STA-Z
will not be able to solve some
of the world's complex problems
of the 21st century,
like refugee crisis and displacement,
I strongly believe that you and I
that are here today,
that happen to be
a little bit privileged,
bear the responsibility to continue
building platforms and systems
that will help refugee children
imagine a better future for themselves,
their families and their communities.
Thank you.
(Applause)